[Music]
learning keeps me going in my 34 years
of career I have seen many things the
course which I did has helped me come
closer to my uh dream of building a
artificial intelligence based
multi-million dollar empire hi I'm Mano
majumdar I live in DHI and I work for
Newen software Technologies limited as
vice president Channel sales in the last
11 years I have set up a partner Network
around 70 countries around the world my
job is to take my team along and create
a network of Partners skill them nurture
them and make them ready for selling in
the global market over the past 34 years
I have seen various Technologies
evolving starting from doors to Windows
to Unix to Linux to uh mainframe
computers I've seen them all and now the
new thing which is coming up is
artificial intelligence I took up the
course uh of AI for decision making by
water and I think now that I couldn't
have taken up any other course uh which
could have done so much of justice and I
think it's a great course the course has
been designed in a way wherein you don't
need to be a programmer you don't
actually need to be even an IT
professional to understand this course
plus what they have done is they have
divided the course into multiple small
small sections in every section you have
a test they have explained it in a very
simple way they have explained it
linking it to the business because it is
self-based it really helps you learn the
way you want to the pace which you want
to follow and it does not really disturb
your family life or your official life
so I also had a a dream to do my own
business in fact I have tried doing it
twice before and this will be my third
attempt and I thought of doing it by uh
using artificial intelligence so what I
think of is using this artificial
intelligence learning and use it in
different software tools which we use or
we create and help themel not just in
India but in the global market I wrote
this book a few months back uh the book
title is lamb leading lines why we don't
have a Google or Microsoft from India I
wrote this book because you know I
always thought that we in India do so
much of work in software uh and our guys
go go out and they had Google they had
Microsoft they had IBM but when it comes
to India we don't have a single billion
dollar Product Company and this became a
a bestseller in Amazon this became a hot
seller for more than a month all big
Journeys start with a small step and I
think upskilling is one of them